Five,
four,
three,
two,
bill,
burr and live.
You look very slick.
He looked like a professional man.
Like I was doing television this
morning.
As I mentioned to you,
I,
I just had Colin cowherd show and I run
out of button down shirts I could wear
on tv because I was go button down and
jeans and whatever.
Nice pair of shoes.
I'm not a sport coat guy,
but I was just like.
I had to go back and Google image myself
on the Shogun.
What did I wear last time I,
I couldn't tell what black shirt I had
on.
It's like,
Oh God,
I gotta throw a sport coat on so I'm
show get trust for that.
Like what do you all Hollywood now man.
Trying to look good.
So yeah,
that's why I'm dressed up here on the
best dressed man in podcasting today.
You are right now for sure.
At this moment.
I am amazed that you actually look to
check to see if you were wearing the
same shirt.
Yeah.
What do you do that for yourself?
You do that because the Internet is
just.
The Internet is nonstop shit.
It's like,
why help them out?
I mean,
it's like if you're going to trash me,
that's,
I'm going to make your work for it.
I'm not going to give you the lay up.
It's such a mild trashing.
I mean,
it's coming from me.
I dress like a fucking idiot and it
just,
you know,
it just,
it's just,
is what it is.
It's just like,
for whatever reason,
I mean,
I don't know.
I get a kick out of doing stuff like
that.
Like Ah,
which way they're going to come at me
today.
Just make them make them better at it.
Oh,
I said the you bald headed blah,
blah,
blah second every fucking day.
It's so.
But to get somebody to come at you in a
thank you,
to get you in a unique way.
Um,
if they get me in a unique way,
it actually makes me laugh and then
there's entertainment for me,
but if it's the same old tired shit,
I dunno,
they get me lately for my socks.
I didn't know that you,
you're not supposed to have socks that
kind of cover your ankles.
Like these are acceptable.
These socks are acceptable sucks either
because they're women's socks.
When we were kids and they had a little
ball on rabbit tail on the end,
they looked there with Chris evertts.
What happened?
Remember,
you should have calf high socks.
Those were the shit catfights socks and
you've shorts barely covered your junk.
Exactly.
Now everybody's shorts go down on their
knees and their socks are nonexistent
now,
but the short to coming back up and I
don't like that.
You know,
like I know there's a,
there's,
there's been a lot of that and then they
said that's the anti man man who's so
comfortable with his masculinity and
those hips to Douche bag.
So they like literally wearing like the
old running shorts with the slit going
up the side,
like Macho Comacho.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Who the fuck's wearing those?
Not a bunch,
but I've just seen enough and you just
look at the whole thing.
It's like they literally look like
they're going to go do some Ron Burgundy
sketch or something,
but it's how they walk around and they
act like,
oh no,
just I liked these shorts.
I put a picture of my sneakers and my
socks on instagram the other day,
which is not a smart move anyway.
Like why did I even do that?
I just went running for three miles in
my sneakers and socks recover with dirt,
but the amount of people to shed a my
socks.
It's like,
what's wrong?
What's wrong with it?
If they covered it rankles that's it.
That what's wrong with those socks?
I don't know,
but I don't know,
but there is something wrong with them.
I,
you know,
I can't put my finger on it.
That ribbon around the ribbed for her
pleasure at the top and then like your
sneakers to the,
you know,
if you're going to go run and dirt.
Like those are the ones that do it.
They look very artsy though.
That looks like some shit.
My wife would appreciate if it was on a
canvas,
you know the socks,
no design on your sneakers,
you know,
modern art thing.
The lines go this way and then they go
that way much like life and then they
intersect,
you know,
that type of shit and it's just like,
why don't you just draw a house?
Do you ever go to Lacma?
The La County Museum don't go,
you'll go crazy now.
I,
I don't,
you know,
I think the most important I would enjoy
the tram ride up.
Like this is fun.
This is cool part.
Yeah.
There's a lot of szekely dress.
Older women with like ridiculously weird
glasses.
Like the,
the color of the frames is always some,
you know,
some statements,
you know what I mean?
Some splash of color to let you know
that they have a personality or maybe on
this usage,
I'm probably just intimidated.
No,
you're not intimidated.
It's nonsense.
I went there and there.
I mean we've talked about this before,
but there's a,
there was a box,
like a plexiglass box on the ground.
That's it.
And amber plexiglass box and I thought
it was like some sort of a like maybe a
stand and then like the exhibit's going
in.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
The box was the art.
That's it,
right?
Nothing in it.
Every art form has that.
Every art form has their plastic box
like,
no,
this is standup.
There it is.
Right.
This is a standup comedy special.
Oh,
well,
it's kind of amber.
A little bit like a.
I Mean I get this delight I guess,
but it's just a fucking box.
I mean it looks like something you would
go get it a crate and barrel.
I could build that.
You easily can build that.
You've given me some glue and you gave
me the pieces.
It's probably worth 30 grand.
I know and it's just like.
I would literally put my feet on that in
a second.
You should do you know you got this
booklet for me here,
dear reader.
Kim Jong Il.
He looks like the kind of person you'd
run into in a museum if he had like sexy
or glasses,
that lunatic will probably somehow hear
this and actually go out and get some.
You know that he's skimmed off a dog.
He's dead.
That's not his son.
No,
that's the dad.
What's his son's name?
Kim Jong wound.
Oh,
well it's definitely his kid.
They look just alike.
Did you see that shadow and how many
dumplings do they have a fucking day?
Everybody else in the country's fucking
emaciated look like they just finished
the Tour de France.
These guys are walking around.
Plump.
Yeah,
like they are on the sixth kid.
Dad bought this so smooth and hairless
too.
That just fucking creepy.
I love him.
Did you see that?
What's that guy's name?
[inaudible] eight.
How do you say that guy's name?
Basquiat.
That basquiat painting that went from
$110,000,000.
I want to see what?
Yes,
it did.
You want to see 110 million buys?
You want to get grossed out.
This Japanese who bought it?
Some super billionaire character who
apparently has another one that he spent
50 something billion or million on 110.
That guy?
Yeah,
that's when you're like eating
endangered species for breakfast.
That stupid fucking painting.
That's $110 million.
It looks like some shit.
I drew when I was a kid and my parents
put it on the refrigerator like,
yeah,
it's great.
There should be like notebook,
like they know that that confetti that
hangs off the side.
Yeah.
What's with the Tic Tac toe on his head
to.
What's that about tic TAC toe and is.
Hey Joe.
It's whatever you want it to me man.
It's all right.
It's up to your own interpretation.
I like the blue.
I always found blue to be soothing a.
The guy looks a little disturbed.
Look at him trying to find his place
within the blue skies of white America.
It's like the left corner.
What did?
He was a little kid and he fucked up and
he just scratched over it like the a and
the b.
But he made the beat backwards and when
Shit and so we just scratched over it.
I just left it there.
Like,
look at that.
What is that?
It's whatever you want it to be.
One hundred $10,000,000.
That's what it is.
And they go,
that's lachman right there.
They would kill to have that piece
hanging in there and there'll be all
kinds of women with weird glasses riding
that train up there to go look at it.
Rubbed the Chins with their gay friends.
Look at him with that guy.
Last bastard.
Now he's killing it.
Dude.
You think so?
Yeah.
Look at him.
He's in great shape with that haircut.
No,
definitely no conditioner.
Huh?
I can't tell if his hair's just starting
to go grey yet.
But isn't that like a billionaire
genius?
Like you're such a.
you're so good at business that you
forget to put conditioner in your hair
and you get like sleep coming out of
your rye and some hot hot.
He just fucking hoses you off in the
morning.
Just wear this.
I can't.
I just keep thinking.
There was a video that I watched the
other day of Elon Musk from 1998 when he
was first becoming a billionaire and a,
he bought a million dollar car and he
had his million dollar car delivered
with his girlfriend at the time.
We got rid of,
let's say at the same time and you all.
My girlfriend put her in the trunk,
but it's so funny to see him as this
young Dork who's,
you know,
just making shit tons of money and his
hair's all goofy and he has this million
dollar car delivered.
Who's this?
Elon Musk.
He owns Tesla.
Tesla.
Okay.
Did you see what you see what he's doing
now?
But the video is hilarious.
Have you seen what he's doing now?
The boring company.
Didn't know what that is.
Where they make like electric jets or
something?
No,
that boring holes underneath Los
Angeles.
He's gonna bore these earthquake proof
tunnels and they're going to put sleds
on these tunnels that go 125 miles an
hour.
So you drive onto the sled,
it locks you in and it shoots you from
like downtown La to wherever the fuck
you're going in.
You know?
Is this it Jamie?
So this is how it works.
You drive onto this sled,
it drops you down,
guy just gets it lists.
It drops you down below the surface of
the earth.
Now,
one of these others,
other.
These are sleds.
So your car is amazing.
I want that to happen.
It's gonna happen,
this crazy fucker.
He's gonna make it and these sleds,
I mean you can't crash into anybody so
they can go stupid fast.
So they're going 125 miles an hour now.
Now,
now they're created by men.
So at some point somebody is going to
not tighten something down.
Well,
those teslas don't have the best service
record as far as or reliability record.
Sam Harris has broke down twice already
and I know other,
another guy who got one in the handle,
stop coming out like you know,
you go near it and handle comes out.
He can break into your own an electric
car.
But look at this.
Another guy gets to get in.
There was going to be align traffic jam
to get onto these fucking things,
but look at this passage way system that
he's devising is going to be crazy.
There's going to be these passageways
all throughout the bottom of the earth.
So underneath the surface of the,
of Los Angeles will be on the streets,
but of course it's going to cave in,
right?
It's going to.
It's got to somehow compromise the
structure.
The city,
right.
All those building,
sitting on top of it.
Uh,
I don't know if anybody can figure it
out.
It would be.
I think that's beyond my pay grade
ground.
I will,
you know,
is most more,
even more amazing than that is that
Japanese built billionaire.
It looked like the Japanese Charles
Bronson.
If you go back,
I love Charles Bronson.
He does a little bit.
He looks tough like Charles Bronson and
the mechanic.
Like that one.
I've seen all his fucking movie.
I love all that.
He,
I've,
I've even watched his Cologne ad that he
did over there.
Oh yeah.
What he saw,
he saw the,
uh,
you saw the softest side of.
Oh yeah,
he's taking his shirt off.
You spin it around this realignment.
Yeah.
It was very.
Not Charles Bronson.
That's back when stars would do for some
reason only in this country.
It was,
it hurt your career if you did a
commercial,
but you could always overseas,
you know,
do something like that you could just
use to hurt their career.
But it doesn't seem to anymore.
Like not only does it not now,
it's like a move.
Now it's like,
why aren't you just going up vacuuming,
vacuuming up this cash?
Yeah.
Like now,
matthew mcconaughey.
Look at him.
Look at that.
I'm telling you,
I nailed it.
He's got to Charles Bronson.
He's got to work on the hair though.
He's got the fucking mustache is a
little too humble with a smile.
He used to be a little more solemn.
Just just accept the fact you're a
baller.
Billionaire pays $110 for a stupid
painting.
He does.
You know what?
Going back to what he does look a little
lost.
Maybe he just doesn't like his picture
taken.
I'm always looking to give somebody the
benefit of the doubt here or maybe he's
realizing they just spent $110,000,000
on a stupid fucking painting and he's
like,
what?
What did it sell for the last time?
I don't know.
That's interesting.
It's good question.
I wonder what he saw and see if he could
find that commercial.
The Charles Bronson Cologne commercial.
I want to say that it's got to be
online.
Why would you tell people that you
bought that and then that's in your
house like didn't nobody learned
anything from the fucking Kardashians.
Look at all the jewelry I got.
Next thing you know you're face down
with a fucking gun to the back of your
head.
You've got to watch out with that.
This guy's fucking.
He's got 110.
It was like a million dollar ring.
He's got like 100,
$10,000,000
piece of art with.
The crazy thing about the Kardashian
thing was that it was in Paris and she
brought security with her.
She had security with her and they
figured out how to get past security.
Yeah,
but everything's better in Europe,
isn't what?
Everybody says that the criminals are
better than our security.
There's Charles Bronson.
Oh,
this is Charles Bronson laid in his life
to this deathwish.
Charles Bronson.
Yeah.
Paul Kurzy.
It's like a mini movie.
Yes.
What was this for?
What?
A country.
Somewhere like in Japan.
Yeah.
They definitely didn't do it here.
What a weird drive.
The guide.
That gate.
Good night,
Mr Bronson sleep tight.
Now we're driving off drives a command.
Now all of a sudden it gets,
here we go.
Oh Wow.
Which gets actually coming off.
What in the fuck is this?
This is a man getting paid.
He's got his pipe on his shirt off.
He's by himself.
You don't realize how jack this guy was.
Oh yeah.
So back then.
Not only that,
he was probably 60 at the time,
like Charles Bronson,
I believe when he watched him to
Tarantino Shit here with shooting guns
and stuff.
This is late in his career too.
I'm telling you,
he might've been 60 here because when he
was in hard times he was 50
man.
Damn man.
That's beyond.
That's the kingdom of a man.
What you're putting on them.
Their to 1976.
It says find out when hard times was.
Oh,
Japanese bandom man to that works over
there.
Hard Times was what?
Seventy five.
So he was 51 when he did that.
Wow.
Checked in the range.
Yeah.
Well it could have been hard times.
He was five.
I bet they sold a ton of that.
Look at that.
That's a 50 year old men know hgh.
No testosterone,
just fucking pushups,
sit ups and drinking milk.
He grew up in a linear work in mines and
stuff in Poland or something.
Yeah,
those guys.
All those guys back then.
You know what I like about those old
movies.
So many of them is when you watch an
army movie from back then you're
watching someone who was in the army and
shot at people.
So it's like they actually,
you know,
Lee Marvin,
like he was one of two people to survive
in his platoon.
Shay,
I got shot and stuff.
Yes.
I think this psychotic nerve issue with
something from where he got shot or
something like this guy live like,
like actors weren't,
you know what they are now,
where it was a lot of pretend.
I mean,
Jesus,
we've been over in Iraq for 15 years.
I'm sure you could,
you like there's going to be the next
Lee marvins are going to come out of
that.
Um,
maybe.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Do you remember when I just say thanks
Joe.
I do too.
Who is that one guy that was like one of
the first original movie stars and he
was a world war two veteran audie
Murphy.
Is that,
was that his name?
There was a guy who most,
most of them are famous war hero
veterans because of the level of the
draft.
But then it becomes.
What did you do when you were there when
it was like a,
some of the,
some of them,
you know,
they,
they were like,
you know,
infrastructure or whatever.
And then there's other people that were
actually like,
upfront this is happening.
This is the guy he was,
he became a movie star.
We'll look at all this stuff on his
coat.
He must've done something over there.
He was a,
he was a decorated.
Okay.
So it's one of the most decorated
American combat soldiers in World War
Two.
And then a single handedly held off an
entire German.
That's the guy ran up with the Canadian
soldiers for an hour.
Yeah.
Wow.
So then he came back and became a movie
star and like people knew he enjoyed a
21 year acting career and then it just
stopped.
Well,
he didn't even like the Congressional
Medal of honor is like,
most people don't win that and they're
still alive.
Right.
So back then that was like a celebrity
like you,
you had to hold off an entire platoon
for a German platoon two,
it makes Porsche's and Mercedes like
their,
you know,
their level of guns that they had over
there.
Like our machine guns overheated and
theirs didn't.
So if you killed a German guy,
you threw,
you threw away the American shit and
picked up their stuff.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
One of my favorite quotes ever,
one of the German tank commanders was
saying every one of their,
uh,
where they,
pantsers is that what this was called?
And I was with the Sherman tanks,
a German tiger.
A tiger was worth like four American
tanks,
but the Americans always had five.
We just totally McDonald's to billions
and billions.
Sarah,
we just kept cranking it out.
It was like we got them right.
And then they'd always be that last one
coming over the hill.
Well,
they had some massive canon in world war
one that apparently you took like 100
men to move this enormous fucking cannon
and a Dan Carlin was talking about it.
A little hard men.
Hardcore history.
What's 100 blue white men to move it?
They wouldn't let anybody without blue
eyes moved.
The thick.
Did hit live in have blue eyes.
That was weird.
He was.
He was a dark haired guy.
No,
he did.
He looks like a cab driver in Germany.
He was everything he hated.
That was the funny thing about it was
not a good dancer.
If you ever saw him do his victory.
Jigs definitely was afraid of dogs.
Really.
I'm just repeating shit that said
jeopardy.
It is amazing to kind of engineering
that German people have come up with.
When you think about Mercedes,
Porsche,
Audi,
BMW,
out of this one part of the world.
No,
and they evidently a lot of the leaders
felt,
oh my God,
look at that fucking cannon.
What is that thing called most powerful
gun ever built?
Heavy Gustov railway gun.
So they put this thing on.
It looks like it's on tractor tires,
like it looks like a tractor.
Right?
And they're there.
I guess they drove this thing up,
but uh,
it just had,
just,
just the way Dan Carlin described it as
incredible,
like this unbelievable shockwave.
Everybody,
you have to run a mile away when the
thing was going off and plug your ears
up just because it'll blow your eardrums
literally apart.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
They show this thing going off.
What's wrong with people?
Oh,
how is war still legal?
I just don't get how that's legal,
you know what I mean?
Like I can't walk into a bar,
you know,
it punch somebody in the face if they
punched me,
be like fucking go to jail.
But like this shit is like,
can't these leaders just kind of solve
things amongst themselves?
No,
they can't carve it up a little.
Just I listen.
You take the Philippines and now you
give us Guam for the uh,
like,
uh,
you know,
owners of football.
Isn't it amazing that we even have
what's legal and what's not legal?
I mean,
what does that mean?
Wrote it down on paper.
We all agreed,
I mean thinking about the shit that
isn't isn't legal and the fact that war
is on that list at all.
I like laws to you.
Like what ones
you can't beat the shit out of him.
He can't come into my house and take my
stuff.
What am I going to do?
What am I honestly going to do about it?
I was thinking about that when I was
watching the UFC this past weekend.
I was watching this,
a frightful beating that Alexander
Gustafson put on glover to share and it
was just a ruthless knockout,
just fucking vicious beat down and then
eventually stopped him and I was
thinking it's kind of crazy that these
guys agreed to do this.
They agree to do this.
Everybody signs away and then you go do
something that anywhere else in the
world you would get locked down.
You arrested.
That happens in hockey every once in
awhile where somebody goes too far and
then the government gets involved.
Really?
Yeah.
Like what do they do if you hit somebody
in the head with a stick that goes
outside the boundaries of a setting,
the tone that seems like a pussy move
though.
Hit Him with a stick.
You're supposed to punch.
It's so weird when you got the stick in
your hand,
you know it,
it just the shit that you sometimes
think of doing it each other in the
balls.
They fucking whack at the bay.
There's no padding behind your legs.
And just imagine that just taken,
taking a would stick it just ah,
with NHL level strength and just given
someone a two hander,
the backlight they break people's finger
crosby on was,
took somebody's finger off this year.
If they get too far,
look,
if it gets really.
If they just opened the rules up a
little bit,
you know what's gonna Happen?
They're gonna.
Bring in figure skaters and they're
going to teach them taekwondo and
they're going to cut people's fucking
heads off the
skates.
Dude,
you're spinning,
man.
If you ever learned how to skate,
you'd
be fucking dangerous.
If you ever did that with skates on,
that would be it.
That's what I'm saying.
If you teach that to somebody,
teach that to somebody with skates.
I mean if you could hit someone with a
hockey stick,
why can't you hit him on skate on the
line here?
Can hit them with this slip.
They do it.
Somebody does it to you now.
They slashed and they do stuff like
that.
You can't club somebody over.
I mean even slashing so.
Okay.
I'll just slash your leg out.
What would you rather have?
Would you rather have tickets get hit by
a piece of wood and you don't have a
bruise there or have somebody slashy
with escape?
I would absolutely rather get hit by the
piece of wood,
but I shouldn't get hit by the piece of
wood.
I don't.
I don't play hockey,
but if I did play hockey I'd be pretty
pissed.
If somebody hit me with a stick.
I built like you fucking pussy and I'd
want to hit a like the second coming of
Thai Domi.
You have the exact same build.
He's a fucking guy who somehow was like
my height and was considered a
heavyweight fighter and he's the guy
according to him,
he came up with the,
grab them by,
right,
right underneath your collar and then
turn all the way sideways because he
didn't have the reach advantage.
Oh.
And then he would,
he would wait for them to throw he duck
under and then come over the top.
And Dude,
I,
I met him one time,
great fucking guy.
And he,
he's got these.
Has like your hands,
use your hands.
You make like that.
It turns into a hammer.
It's the same thing.
He has like these inexplicable,
like bare fucking pause and I might be a
little taller than him.
And I remember when he's tried to show
me when he grabbed the front of my shirt
to show me,
like,
I literally felt like an adrenaline,
like a flashback.
I hope this guy doesn't snap.
Now he's one of the,
like these.
He's one of the toughest guys that ever,
uh,
ever played.
Well,
you know,
when Rocky Marciano was the heavyweight
champion,
he was the only 185 pounds is 185 pounds
and he was 5:10.
He was the heavyweight champion.
That's because it wasn't Tim Horton's on
everybody's every fucking corner.
They wouldn't feed and cows the other
cows and be like,
I had needed.
See what happens.
Kids hit puberty at like eight.
Now you got to like teach them how to
shave.
I mean,
I don't know what is in a hormones.
Well,
who knows what it is,
but it's no lump.
Monsanto change their,
uh,
their name.
You know what I mean?
What do they know?
I don't know what shit that's,
that's the genius of it.
Because then you don't know it the same
way.
Halliburton changed the same way Nissan.
Nissan changed from,
from Dotson.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
Wonder why they do that.
Dotson do made some good cars.
Oh,
there.
They always go over the cliff.
Toyota did that too with Alexis.
The dots and I want to get fucking sued.
Honda and Toyota in this country,
they both do the same thing.
They have this weird division where they
make a luxury brand for Americans.
You know,
they don't do like Acura and Honda.
They don't do that in Japan.
Like if you buy an Nsx in Japan,
which the top end car,
it's a Honda.
It's a Honda Nsx.
Okay.
But in America we're like,
no,
you need something.
You need a better name.
No,
but we have this space.
Are you saying that they can't get a
luxury car over there?
No,
no,
no.
They changed the name in America because
we don't.
We don't want buy a Toyota.
We assume a Toyota is a cheap car.
So they go,
okay,
well we're going to make a different
brand of Toyota and call it a lexis.
And everybody's like,
okay,
we're in.
So long as he changed the name.
Oh,
okay.
I always list literally gonna make up
without any research that because they
weren't an island want to drive.
They don't have anywhere to drive,
so they don't.
They don't let them fast cars.
Even that guy with $110,000,000,000
to buy a picture,
it's got nowhere to go now.
He has like a civic.
He's,
he can't spend his money on cars,
so that's why buys the art.
You're a car guy though,
you know,
they have pretty fast cars.
I mean they have ridiculously fast cars.
They have the GTR.
It's one of the fastest cars in the
world.
I know,
but I've never been there.
So you can.
Yeah.
I just started to listen to what you
were saying and then then that whole
theory developed in my head.
Japan is small,
but it's not that small.
No,
it isn't.
Can I mention that is for family that it
came out today.
That's why I'm here.
That's why I dragged you out of bed or
whatever you were doing to do the
special podcast,
which I appreciate.
Um,
I season to season two of F is for
family,
is available for,
to stream all of it.
It took us a year to make it and you can
devour it in five hours.
Wow.
If you have food delivered and then you
can ask me when season three coming out,
which is what I hope you ask me,
because that would mean that you enjoyed
it.
I love this fucking show.
It's a hilarious show.
Oh,
I'm looking forward to the season.
It's fun and I work with great people.
Thank God.
Because if I didn't the amount of work
that it was,
it would actually be misery.
But it isn't work though.
How much work does it take you a,
like it takes a year to make,
but how much does it take?
How long does it take you?
Well,
I mean the writers room is like a,
uh,
you know,
like a 10 week,
11 week thing and then you're recording
as you go and then you're looking at,
you know,
the first drawings of it with a sort of
rough it out and be like,
no,
I have frank standing over here and
sue's over here and then it just Kinda,
you just keep.
Then you rewrite and then you watch and
stuff and it doesn't play and then you
rewrite it and it just.
Yeah,
it takes a year,
dude.
It takes like 10 months and then the
last two months is just going okay.
Deciding on strategies on how they're
going to a promoted,
which amazed me because I'm like,
well we'll fucking do what we always do,
but like this business just changes so
rapidly that even how we promoted it
when it first came out in December 2015,
you know,
which is almost 2016.
So now we're in 2017.
Like it's a bunch of other stuff has
changed since then.
So I don't know like what,
what's changed?
What do you mean?
I fucking knew you were gonna ask me.
Sorry.
I'll just let you go.
I can't.
What was it?
No more questions.
No,
they would just go in like they brought
me,
they
brought me in.
Maybe this is my standup special.
That's why they brought me in and they
showed.
They basically showed me how everybody's
Netflix screen is different.
Like yours is different than your
homepage is different because it's all
there just watching you watch
tv or they got this fucking thing that
watches it.
So the only way our screen within our
top whatever be the exact same as if we
watch the exact same shit at the same
time.
And maybe even the same age group,
I have no idea,
but I was blown away by that.
Like I just thought like,
you know,
I would look and be,
oh man,
my specials on,
on the cover of Netflix.
It's like,
no,
it's on the cover of yours.
And whoever else is in that,
that vibe of like you're gonna like
this.
I have three different profiles of one
profile and then I have one profile for
each of my kids.
Okay.
So I see different stuff.
So I see that.
So if I go to my kid's homepage,
like if they want to watch a show that
they watch and I go there,
I see just a bunch of little kids show.
I don't ever see anything that I watch.
I go to mine,
I see house,
a car,
the car special as the other people's
specials.
So yeah,
that's what they do.
This,
they're very smart with their
algorithms.
But what I don't like is this fucking
thumbs up,
thumbs down,
bullshit.
I can't do that.
What?
That.
I was joking about that on my podcast.
It's like a,
a Adolf Hitler,
thumbs down,
orange juice after brushing your teeth,
thumbs down.
You know what I mean?
It's true.
Ice Cream,
thumbs up threesome with supermodel.
Thumbs up.
Yeah.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Did they really do that because of Amy
Schumer.
That's the.
No,
no,
that was.
That was already.
Yeah,
they do that.
Why would they do that?
The hemophilia,
when you're that fucking big,
you can't make decisions that quickly,
but everybody wanted it to be done for
her.
Identify.
Well,
you know,
they got to bring it back.
The star system is a perfect system.
Everybody's used to it.
Yes.
Has been using it forever.
It works.
Yes,
but what is this star is starts.
Somebody told me the star system only
applies.
It's like geared towards what you would
like.
I'm like,
how the fuck would they know that that
doesn't make any sense.
And then I heard that that's not the
case,
that it's basically just a,
an average of all the people.
Just like on Amazon,
if you go to Amazon and you look at
something,
you see five stars and you see 175
reviews,
that's what it is.
Right.
But somebody told me that wasn't the
star system,
wasn't that.
See if he could find that out.
Jamie.
Somebody said the star system was based
on whether or not you would like it.
I'm like,
that seems ridiculous because I've never
rented a fucking thing in my life on
him.
On netflix.
I don't get any of these places and I
don't understand how any of them fucking
work.
I just,
I go old school,
like I just tried it.
Whatever I'm doing,
I try to make it as funny as I possibly
can and try to work with the best people
I possibly can and then just hope it
sticks.
If it doesn't,
I can always just keep telling jokes.
Other than that,
I don't know what to tell you.
I have no idea.
I was fuck when I took that meeting with
Netflix.
I wouldn't even like,
this is a jerk off meeting.
Why did I drive all the way over here to
fucking have a meeting on how to promote
this shit and when they sat down and
they were done with the presentation,
I always am.
I allowed to leave.
Like you don't do the men in black thing
to me before I walk out of here.
So I forget all that was fucking
amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
Like the with which every goddamn like
there's not one drop of water that rolls
off the table.
They'd like their,
they're catching it all.
I don't know how they,
you know,
I'm just not wired that way.
Well that's probably good though.
There's only so much
time of the day,
like just to think about being funny and
just concentrate and stay in your lanes.
Probably the best option anyway
is that I.
I mean it's working for me.
Yeah,
it's working for me.
And then there's also worried about
algorithms and then there's also a
certain level of known that you don't
want to get to because then it stops
being fun.
And then Tom Cruise does A.
Yeah,
well early Tom Cruise.
It was fun to be that famous,
but before social media and everybody
had a camera that they could pull out
like Charles Bronson and that alone
commercial.
Then it just becomes.
It's just something completely
different.
Like when we started in this business
like being famous
court side seats and I don't know,
look at the shock and mountains of blow.
Here's the.
It says Netflix star systems.
Star Star ratings were personalized and
had been from the start.
That means when you saw a movie on
Netflix rated four stars didn't mean the
average of all the ratings were forced
ours,
and instead it meant that Netflix
thought you'd rate it four stars based
on your habits and other people's
ratings,
but many people didn't get that.
So how the fuck was Amy Schumer's
Onestar?
Everybody gave it one star.
How's that?
How's that work?
That was Sandinista rebels just.
They just all got on and then they
threatened the people that liked her
specialty.
That's how it went down.
Well,
I guess in that case what they did was
they just said,
look,
Greenpeace attacked by so many,
it just ruined all my chances for the
rest.
I did this joke about trees and they
just didn't like it.
And that's it for me.
That works.
Now.
This is a whole new world.
Um,
that seems weird though to me that they
wouldn't like let it actually be rated
that they,
the ratings were personalized based on
the shit that you liked.
But how the fuck do they know what you
like?
You just know what I watched it.
So it's a riddle wrapped up in an
enigma.
You're not going to figure out a fucking
worldwide.
I don't know how they do it.
I don't know how to.
All I know is I went and I took the
meeting.
I was like,
this is fucking unbelievable.
Or they're on top of shit.
You know,
the weirdest one is Alexa.
Alexa,
the Amazon one.
They're using it.
The trainings.
I was like a porn star.
Yeah,
it does.
I'm sure there's a bunch of the stage
Alexa.
They're trying to use that.
Alexa is a thing that you talk to you
like Alexa,
play bill burrs album,
and you know I have no sympathy for
people that bring that in their house
and because those mouth breathing
fucking morons will someday will be
mandatory that I do and get microchipped
and then that's going to be the end of
any sort of rebellion and whatever the
fuck they want to do,
that's it.
The emperor can literally fuck a
flounder on TV at that point and they
will be able to stop any sort of like
fucking any dissent,
any dissent.
They'll turn off your chip,
which is your money.
What are you gonna rebel against the
slip with a slingshot.
It's over.
It's a rap,
but
there's too many mouth breather and
morons being like,
well,
why do I care if somebody,
if I'm not fucking door and a thing?
Those people.
Yeah,
I've.
I've had the.
I had that argument with a very smart
person when the NSA shit went down and
they found that they were listening to
the calls.
Guys like,
go ahead,
listen.
If it keeps fucking terrorists from
attacking,
go ahead and listen.
I'm not doing anything wrong,
like,
wow,
that's not.
That's not what it is.
Like anybody could find out your email,
they can go in your email,
look at your emails and decide whether
or not you're doing something wrong or
right.
Decide they don't like that.
Once they have that jurisdiction,
that could even.
Even if it didn't have anything,
they could say you did.
Yeah,
definitely.
Kit,
they get they.
They could alter your emails.
They could do whatever they want.
That's nobody gets whacked anymore.
People used to get whacked.
You don't get whacked anymore in any
kill.
You though.
Will they think that seth rich guy got
killed?
Who said paying attention to that?
Listen to shit.
I just talk.
I'm just gonna say you could just kill
them in the media one dick pic.
It'd be like,
that is his dick.
I'll give you the conspiracy theory and
I gave you what they know.
There's a guy named seth rich.
She's apparently a Bernie Sanders
supporter.
He's working for the DNC.
Found out that the DNC was democratic.
National Convention.
Natural.
Yeah.
National Chanel.
He found out that they were fucking over
Bernie Sanders,
and so he supposedly was giving this
information to wikileaks.
All that information got out,
it hurt Hillary because it turned and it
hurt the DNC,
the DNC head of the DNC left,
and when she resigned and immediately
went to work for Hillary Clinton.
Anyway,
this guy who wiki leaks and there was no
followup because once she resides in
mainstream news.
That's the end of the fucking story.
Yeah.
There was no follow.
It was pretty outrageous that she
immediately got hired by Hillary
Clinton.
Right.
But anyway,
the kid who was as Bernie Sanders
support,
his name is seth rich,
he was murdered outside of his house,
4:00
in the morning.
They said it was a robbery.
They left his money.
He left his wallet,
he left his phone,
they left his watch.
Nothing was taken from him,
but he was shot in the back at 4:00
in the morning.
So Julian Assan from wikileaks said that
there are consequences for working with
us and providing us information.
So they're saying,
are you saying this guy provided him
information?
He said,
that's just what I'm saying,
there's calm,
there's consequences to work with us,
and then there's this other guy,
Kim dot was this famous,
a multimillionaire internet character
that's hiding.
I was going to say,
after he lets the information out,
what is the purpose of killing the guy
because you're not going to stop the
inflammation.
What it is is to stop other people from
doing it because it'll all get creeped
out by to stop what you're saying here
to stop other people from doing it one
and two so that he can't testify on the
depth of all the corruption that was
going on in the DNC and who had
organized it and who had orchestrated
it.
That's what they think.
But what the fuck who the.
But there's a lot of people that dispute
this.
And also there was a redacted FBI report
that people were touting out that turned
out to be bullshit.
And so now they found out that that was
a fraud,
that the FBI report was a bullshit FBI
reports.
So they don't know what the fuck's going
on,
but this guy's dead.
So my point is he,
he got whacked whether
or not he got whacked because he was
working with.
There it is.
Federal prosecutor found dead.
This guy got whacked this weekend
apparently.
Oh,
Jesus will work for.
They'll know exactly yet.
Jesus,
you just blew my theory out of the water
and was like a 37 year old federal
prosecutor went for a jog and south
beach and uh,
found with a gunshot wound to his head,
I believe.
It's like,
well,
he might've fucking put somebody in jail
though.
That potentially.
Yeah.
That was pissed off.
And waited for him at all.
To your behaviors.
What?
When you put someone in jail when you.
Yeah,
when you have jobs like that.
Oh yeah.
You can't be.
You can't go home the same way.
Everything.
But I had a fuck.
People live like that.
Yeah.
How do you live with your prosecutor to
ever get to that level of society?
Well,
it's just a intense way of life to your
work with criminals all the time.
You're constantly working with people
that are breaking the law.
You're constantly trying to put them
behind bars.
I guess it's freaking me out,
dude.
When did you start smoking a pipe?
Oh,
I only have only have done it a couple
of times.
Steven crowder brought it in for me and
I try.
How is it?
It's not bad.
It's not amazing because you got stopped
out.
I'll do it right now.
I'll light up for you.
I thought it would be amazing.
That's okay.
Both my grand grandfather smoked a pipe,
so I am a uh,
you know,
I like what it looks like.
There's a place,
uh,
on the west side,
the tinderbox then I've been meaning to
go into that place on Wilshire,
right?
Isn't it?
Yes.
I know that's bought is a place over
there and I've been meaning to go in
there and take up.
Piped him.
I just,
I don't know.
I just liked,
I liked the smell of it.
This is dead.
We got to go in there and throw your
shirt across the room and starts smoking
a pipe.
Well,
the why you liked that?
I'll tell you a little bit about efforts
to family for people this season.
A frank looking to get his job,
get a job I should say,
after getting fired,
and that was some good active listening.
Oh Jesus.
I'm.
Is it,
we'd,
you're putting in there.
It's tobacco.
Inhale.
Do you know?
And you just sort of put it in your
mouth.
Okay.
Just gonna get a little there.
Kevin's trying to get his band going.
We got Laura dirt on the show.
Justin Long.
Sam Rockwell.
Haley reinhart.
Debbie dairy berry.
Think I might've been hailed the first
time tonight.
I thought you did.
I might've.
We'll see how it goes.
David Kempner.
No,
that time I did.
It was a funny guy.
Yeah.
He's,
he's one of the silliest people I've
ever met and I love him.
Yeah,
you guys got a great cast.
Yeah.
Do you like doing a cartoon?
Is it,
is it as satisfying for you was doing
standup or is it just something
different that's equally satisfying?
It's just fun.
Just,
you know what my.
No,
no,
it's,
yeah,
the standups.
My first love.
So,
but the thing that I love doing is I
love writing for all these other people,
you know.
And I should say we,
when we write for them,
because everybody's in the room and the
biggest thrill I get is at the table
read beyond making,
you know,
the powers that be laugh when the actors
crack
up and they can't get through the line.
Like we got mo collins this year a
couple of times that she's just a,
she's a beast man.
She's just does so many characters for
us.
And a couple times like,
it's just one of those things like,
man,
we're making mole laugh.
Like I know this is a good line.
And um,
we,
we got those guys.
Trevor Deval is another guy.
We got him one time and collectors hard
to get to laugh though.
He's such a pro,
you know what I mean?
And he'll say afterwards,
this is some of the funniest shit I've
ever done.
But he to get him kind of a kind of a
goal of mine to get them to crack.
Yep.
I've been in the booth with Laura and
we've gotten her a number of times and
uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
Sam Rockwell.
We've gotten them left.
I just love,
that's my favorite.
My favorite,
it's like making another comedian left.
It's an extra level of like,
all right,
you know,
especially,
a lot of them,
the caliber of actors that,
the material that they've looked at.
So for them to say,
and he can tell,
you know,
anybody can say,
oh my God,
this is great.
But when you really make them laugh,
you can't fake that.
Um,
so I,
I read the table reads of fun because I
think that's more like a standup show
and um,
I really rehearsed my lines and I make
sure that I,
you know,
I sell the shit out of him because uh,
I don't have to go back and fix them,
you know,
if they don't work at the table reading,
that's something that I did accidentally
early in my career.
And then I learned what a,
um,
you know,
I learned what a big thing that is,
like the first acting gig that I got,
I was doing some small movie or
something.
They had a table read and I got there
and I was overly prepared and the lines
worked.
And then there was more stuff for me.
And this guy said,
hey man,
the writers love you man,
you just selling the shit out of your
stuff.
And I'm thinking my head as I was just
trying not to get fired.
And then I,
then I was able to see how the game
works because there's,
there's actors that will go to a table
reading if they don't like the material,
they don't sell the stuff and the,
I don't think they understand how hard
people work.
So at least give it a fucking yes.
Swing out of your cleat,
see what happens,
you know what I mean?
But to go there and just sort of mumble
your way through it,
the that's,
it's not a good position to get yourself
into as an actor of the whole writing
room.
Writer's room was like,
Oh
fuck this guy.
Yeah.
It wasn't that an issue on what was that
girl on one of those cop shows,
not cop shows.
One of those hospital shows,
grey's anatomy was that girl said she
wanted to be removed from consideration
for,
for the Emmy's because she didn't think
the material is strong enough that year.
And they were like,
Oh,
what?
Oh God,
this fly.
No.
And,
and how,
how writers?
Yeah.
Command their money is through winning
shit like that.
Yeah.
Obviously it had been on a hit show,
but if you're an emmy award winning
writer,
that's huge for that.
That's like their fucking hbo special.
So to screw.
If they're gonna get.
They were nominated and she said,
I want to take that back.
We didn't want to be.
She didn't want to be nominated.
Here it is.
Star shuns Emmy's.
Katherine Heigl this week said she had
opted out of the Emmy's racist here
because she was not given good enough
material to work with last season that,
that fucking 29 years old on top of the
fucking world just disappear and up your
own fucking vagina.
Back to that real quick.
So that was.
I don't.
That is exactly.
She's still working.
Not really,
no.
She dropped off the face of the planet
10 years ago.
She was a big star.
She started doing movies.
She did that movie with Seth.
Does she know she's fucking dropped off
the face of the planet now she's 40 and
38.
Let's be honest here.
She's 38.
Well basically 10 years ago,
40 years.
30 eight mean I'm 49.
I'm 50.
Trust me.
That's what happens though.
That 10 years flies by and nobody wants
to do shit with you anymore and now
she's got a tainted word.
She's got a tainted name.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
She's apparently softened their stance
and she's,
you know,
apologized for her,
her youthful exuberance.
But Hey,
we're dumb.
She the twenties with dump.
Yeah.
I give her a pass.
Thomas.
Fuck yeah.
I give a passport girl.
Good for you.
What are you going to do?
Dumb shit in your twenties.
That's pretty dumb though.
Huh?
That's pretty dumped.
That's ferocious.
I can beat that with a few things in my
twenties.
Don't you think?
That's not like a rash decision.
That's something that was thought over.
Decided,
reinforced.
Said it more than one time and then.
But there's a certain level of like not
only ego mania was celebrity with Asos,
so paranoia and I think that like you
just fucking did all squirrels together
in your head and like,
you know,
like maybe her thinking about an old
acting,
am I doing the work?
He says,
he says worthy.
He got that fucking going on.
If you're just remotely a pleasant
person when you get to a certain level
of fame,
people just like you are just the most
amazing.
Like I sneezed and you said God bless
you.
I mean he is so down to earth like the
level that you have to just fucking
barely even be a fucking decent human
being to just get this avalanche of
compliments.
If you got that going on and then you
got this fucking paranoia thing,
like a is this to move?
This is what I wanted.
Is this what I want to hang my hat on
with this man?
You just start fucking heaven.
Your own inside the actor's studio with
yourself.
I think it's just a diss on the writers.
That's what I would say.
I would say what she's doing is dissing
the writers.
She's just saying when your world,
it's a sketch.
For me,
it was a,
uh,
it was a trilogy of a movie.
I was really going somewhere with
trilogy three,
three parter.
I was just joking how I built it all up
in her head.
And you're just like,
yeah,
I think you're just being a cunt.
They call them all brass tacks.
Rogan just gets right down to it.
That is my method.
I'm more of a bro.
I'm not really.
I'm not grounded.
Pumped.
You grounded,
pounded.
Don't feel them out in the first round.
You take them right down.
Back when it comes to people like that.
I've seen that before.
I know what that is.
You go double leg take down and then
that's it.
Especially with the actors.
I've,
I mean I've met a lot of Nice actors,
don't me wrong,
but maybe it's fifth 50 percent of them.
That's a bad number.
Like 50 percent of actors are pretty
fucked up.
But you worked.
You worked back when they could be a
Douche.
That's true.
Now you can't.
That's right.
Yeah.
People tell.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's just because everybody's stole all
the movies and they stole all the music.
You know,
there's people like weasel.
The good music was born during the
grunge era.
It's like,
well,
if this model existed back then you
would have ruined that too because you
don't pay for anything.
So you get what you pay for it.
You get shitty movies,
you know,
about superheroes and all that.
So now that's what it is.
It's going to be superheroes or uh,
you know,
some sort of whatever.
Fucking,
oh my God.
Am I 40 now?
One of those comedies and um,
yeah,
what the fuck was my point?
What were you going to pay for anything
anymore made it,
that's what I made.
And that wasn't your thing.
I was talking about,
oh,
you can't be a Dushan out because the
work is dried up.
There's not as many of them.
That's why this like,
like all these stars pilot on like the
Golden State Warriors.
Every movie back in the day like to to
make Ocean's 11 happened when all of
those people could have had their own
starring vehicle and make all of this
fucking money.
God,
I hope I'm right on this one.
You mean the original oceans 11 now.
Even though even the one when i.
The few times I did movies,
everybody told me you just missed it.
You fucking missed it at all.
Ended in Oh,
five.
Oh six.
And I started getting work in like
fucking oh nine,
2010.
They were like,
oh my God,
they'd fucking pay for John Travolta.
Is jet fuel in his own fucking to do
like one of those hogs movies?
Like riding on a motorcycle?
He the okay,
you got to pay for my 7:47
and I got chuck.
Chuck goes without saying it goes
without saying.
I'm going to fly back and forth from the
set on the weekend and my own 7:47,
12 hour apps.
Whatever you want.
We'll build a fucking airfield for you
right next to them.
When we do stay alive,
we'll fucking do like,
like when you hear something,
I mean I'm obviously exaggerating to a
certain level,
but like some of the,
the,
the budgets that were around in the way
that they burned through fucking money
and I'm now it all just,
it's like it's the Serengeti during the
dry seasons and all the fucking lines of
fucking everybody's drinking next to
each other.
So don't they still make big movies now?
I mean don't all these like a
blockbuster.
They still make no,
but if you notice,
but this like it's not just a Tom cruise
movie.
There'll be like fucking all these other
people pile like those superhero movies,
this like this.
There's someone who used to be able to
carry a movie in each slot.
Right.
I'm not saying they still don't get
movies.
It's just like just just dried up and I,
this people in the industry told me
men in black,
three star will smith forced the moon.
Forced to move is huge.
$2,000,000
trailer as New York residents complain
that trailer as Jim just for working
out.
That's just as Jim.
Yeah,
he had another trailer to holy shit
hanging out or whatever.
Kevin James had a trailer just for
working out.
When we did a zookeeper together.
He had a full gym in a trailer that you
rent.
I mean it was a full.
It had a fucking tanning booths in it.
That was one.
Here comes the boom,
here comes the boom.
He had to get in shape because he was
playing a us,
a guy who became a UFC fighter.
Yeah,
he did a great job.
he did.
He lost a Shitload of weight to start
drinking Kale shakes in the morning and
working out constantly,
so we had a full gym.
Nothing will get you in shape like
knowing you how you're gonna have to
take your shirt off in a movie that will
motivate you.
Like fuck,
this definitely helped me.
All the green shit you got.
I'll drink it.
I will fucking drink that.
If you could somehow,
if there was an app that you listened to
when you were asleep and it convinced
you that you were going to have to take
your shirt off in a movie,
like the level of shape that Americans
would get into.
I think it would be crazy.
Do you.
What about Bert Kreischer?
Bert Kreischer is a rare animal.
He's like a white tiger.
Very valuable.
Like an albino deer.
Like if you ever get to the level,
if you get bored with just,
you know when you want to go for the
ultimate prey,
like that's the head you want on your
wall crisis.
Bert is like A.
Yeah,
he has A.
I don't know.
I don't know how he's wired,
but like a.
He does not.
I,
I would love to add that.
You'd have to ask him that.
Ask Him Bert,
what humiliate you.
Like he like,
dude,
that dude is really just like fearless
was definitely fearless in taking the
shirt off.
Takes his shirt off every show.
Like immediately takes his shirt off and
the push back as a fucking chaps on
chaps ate.
Did that at the Goddamn comedy jam?
No,
he came.
I remember I had a follow up.
He went out and he fucking did a red hot
chili peppers.
Give it away now and came out with just
a sock on his junk.
It convinced everyone else in the band
to do it and they did it.
Most of them didn't want to do it.
He just.
He's fucking burt.
He let them over the hill,
like in braveheart.
They all walked out with this socks and
I'm sitting there like the fuck am I
going to follow this and what did you
have to say?
Why don't you play the drums?
I played drums.
We can't go wrong though,
and you're.
You're back there with the drums.
You could follow that.
It's not the same a dude.
You're talking to the level of energy
and the level of the crowd being like,
dude,
what the fuck show is over to the show.
The show is over.
Why did they have him go last?
I think that's the exact question I
asked Josh.
Adam Meyers who also does expose also
does a voice on how when Hank,
the Dj had the,
where he came up with a DJ character.
I'm like,
I got the guy with the perfect voice.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
I,
I don't know why I should have been
going on la.
I think it's like they,
they view that show more like,
how many years have you been doing
standup?
It's like,
no,
this is not a standup to save music show
who has the most musical ability or like
it's going to make the crowd go the
craziest.
I mean,
come on dude.
Even if you didn't know anything about
show business guys with these
guys are going to come out with nothing
but socks on their dicks.
That's,
that's going last,
right?
Yeah,
that's,
that's it.
So that's what I would say if I was
scheduling it.
I can't remember
what.
I did have two that play the drums.
Why did some stuff I did enough standup
to try and make them forget about what
they saw before that.
But I don't remember what song I played.
So that show us.
Stand up to what you can do little
standup as well with the way it started
out,
which you would come out and just talk
about how much you loved music and then
you talk about the awful bands you
played in or some of the concert you
went to or a.
I'm a rockstar that they meant something
to you.
And,
and what,
what,
what inspired the Doula?
There you go.
That's me being trying to be Steven
Adler Tattoo the tattoo.
Um,
so I probably played either.
Welcome to the jungle of Paradise City
on that one.
Uh,
it's funny shit dude.
And that's the reason why I dress up
like the drummers is because I don't
want people to think that,
you know,
I played drums good enough where people
will be like,
wait,
does this guy think he's good?
Yeah,
there you go.
He's trying to find the socks.
That was before the weight loss
challenge to.
Yup.
He put most of that weight back on
though.
Tommy didn't.
I went to Tommy's house the other day to
do his podcasts.
He looks fucking great.
He's lost more weight.
Oh yeah.
He's disciplined now.
They see us exercising constantly,
eerily quiet sometimes.
When you stand next to Tom?
Yes.
Really?
Yeah.
I just peer into his head sometimes like
what's going on in there?
What do you say?
What is.
I don't know.
I don't know if this I love top,
but I'm telling you these just have it
in there.
I would love to bring them on here and
interview him.
Well,
he's definitely intense.
He's.
He doesn't show a lot of people like the
way he prepared for this weight loss
challenge.
How am I dark dude and I,
I when I go into a room and you can see
if you're a psycho,
you spot another cycle and there's just
like this.
There's a fucking movie going on there
that I would love to finance.
I want to see that movie made
him and his wife.
I think that's the funniest comedy
couple next to Moshe Kasher,
like that's like Moshe Kasher and his
wife a Natasha Leggiero.
Those two.
And then Tommy bonds and Christina.
I kind of go with Tommy and Christina.
They're closed.
I'm seeing a new reality show.
It's close comedy couples,
couples,
chicken and.
Oh yeah,
last comic standing with comic meets the
newlywed game.
Huh?
That's how you.
That's all you have to do to pitch.
You just pitched to shows that worked
the newlywed game and last comic
standing.
Yeah.
You ask them questions and all of that
stuff.
Who else is out there?
You've got Tom Cotter and Carrie Luis.
Right.
Okay.
I'm just saying convenience.
I'm okay.
It's one season mcfarlane and rich vos
bottoming,
which their banders that's there in the
running as well for the funniest couple.
Who else?
Well,
how do you keep this
going,
Joe?
I don't have this going for five seats.
You don't.
You barely can get three episodes.
It is special.
This is something you would learn your
name to know.
Could this live where we're where we're
just trying to get a check.
I just want to sell it to you and then
run away.
I like it.
Well listen,
we just got business with a liquid
draino and they want to get into the
streaming business and they got all
kinds of money.
They know they're going to lose money in
this first year,
so we'll give you.
We'll just go throw money at you.
Okay.
I have one request.
What's that?
Mario Lopez host.
Mario Lopez.
Can we get them that we know him?
Yes.
What does he do?
He's a boxer.
Myra Lopez.
He wasn't on saved by the bell.
Did that too,
but now entertainment reporter slash
boxer.
Oh,
and he's a boxer.
Yeah.
Now the guys read it.
Good looking guy.
And he hosted.
Yes.
There you go.
So like the women are married to a God.
It's not as good looking as Mario.
And that's part of the drama.
The show.
What do you think?
Which is where does this live?
Bravo for sure.
I was just picturing the industry,
like whenever you don't know what to
say,
you just go,
where does this live?
Is this in our Palette?
You know what I been watching lately?
This fucking ridiculously addictive and
some fucked up way is million dollar
listing.
Ever watched that show?
Do you know what it is?
Is.
So gay guys are selling houses.
Yes.
My wife Watches that Shell with that
fucking.
The Gay Guy Lives in Connecticut.
So ridiculous.
So t he looks like he's like claymation,
he doesn't look like a real person.
He's so light.
I am the number one real estate agent
and all of New York.
I liked,
I liked he best.
I love that guy.
And I know when he starts speaking,
what is.
He speaks Swedish and out of nowhere.
He just was not the guy.
That's not him.
No,
that's,
that's the one from new.
No,
that's the other one.
The one of the things.
You got it right guy,
that guy fucking guy.
He is of the one of the little metal
looks a lot like,
um,
God.
That's weird.
They all,
they're all have on lipstick.
They look exactly the same million
dollar listing Los Angeles.
That's the different one.
Yeah,
the one in New York,
one of the greatest fucking gay dude.
I love that guy.
So the guy in the middle is.
I haven't seen that guy before.
I've only seen the one in New York with
a male model in the middle.
There's a middle one on the right is an
angry psycho like me.
The dude in the middle is sort of a
middle ground and then the other guy is
like,
I mean he's right out of Hogan's heroes.
There was a house that they were selling
in Los Angeles that was on that show and
I was watching it and they were trying
to sell it for $20,000,000
and it was for sale recently.
Stood out was actually a house.
It's really for sale but it's like right
above sunset strip.
Like you could see it from the strip,
like you mentioned,
buying a $20,000,000
house and you could just look at it like
you can look into the windows.
I mean it's a half a block above the
strip.
You looking out your window like a cvs
is across the street?
No.
Yeah,
that's what.
Okay.
I just thought you were.
But it is like that.
I mean it's stair steps above it.
It's here's the strip,
here's sunset strip.
Here's the first couple of buildings is
right there.
I mean it's fucking right there,
but it's true.
They want $20,000,000
from and the listings.
You believe that those are true because
like the last episode I watched is the,
uh,
the Gay Gestapo guy is sitting there
going,
he walks in to this lady and he just
goes,
okay,
here's the off.
Our final offer that could give you is
11 point $3,000,000.
And then she just said that one,
she read them the riot.
I told you,
negotiation,
waste my fucking time,
blah,
blah blah.
And he's just sitting there going like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
You know?
And I was,
I was surprised he took that level of
shit.
I was waiting for me like,
lady,
I stepped my fault.
You think it's worth $50,
million dollars to fucking lunatic?
I can't do that.
So he just sits there and listens and
then she leaves and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
They finally didn't sell a house.
And then just boom,
two seconds later somebody calls up.
Oh,
after,
after he does the whole,
she walked out the door.
It was like winter in Russia,
right?
Fuck it.
All of a sudden somebody calls up out of
nowhere and just goes,
all right,
11,
six final offer.
That's it,
and then he calls the lady up and then
she's all just like,
see,
that's all I wanted.
Yeah,
that's exact show I watched.
and that was.
That was too easy and there's the
handsome model.
He just takes the shirt off all the time
and he just ripped that guy with the.
The fellow with the light.
My wife likes him.
Of course she does know women like them.
Guys shredded.
Yeah.
I'll kick it back to data for man.
She could literally be like,
I'm leaving you for him.
And I'd be like,
I get that.
I get it.
I see it.
You gotta do what you gotta do go good
for you,
man.
Congratulations.
Give me some knuckles.
Hey,
at least we had a kid together.
Magic magic is taking custody to always
a better looking dad.
He's probably better at it than me.
Yeah,
it's,
it's tough to fight that off.
It was about six to shredded and he
keeps a certain mount chest hair on it
to you really analyze this guy to
fucking not.
I usually I got my little glass of
fucking whatever I'm drinking at that
point.
You know,
my little helper to get me to sleep.
What do you drink a dude?
I drink gasoline.
Gas.
How often do you drink it?
Oh,
because you took a long time off,
right?
Didn't you take like a few months
periods?
Uh,
I'm in the middle of a Joe Dimaggio
streak right now.
I didn't drink last night,
but I had family come in a two weekends
this month to meet my daughter and uh,
so like that was a lot of like,
you know,
beer,
drinking them.
It's just,
you know,
booze and whatever.
Like I feel I'm being good if I drink
hard stuff because it's not as many
calories is beer.
But um,
yeah,
I've been on a wine street,
clearly drinking with the dementia
teeth.
Gray.
I hate that.
Then you're sitting there,
you could drink red wine.
It turns it gray.
Then you're like,
ah,
I drink so much coffee.
My teeth had kind of jacked anyway.
Oh,
they're going a little yellow.
Yeah,
I,
I definitely,
uh,
don't know.
I definitely,
yeah,
I go through peers.
I got inspired recently because I read
something about some celebrity that
fucker was already good looking and then
they just laid off the booze being like,
yeah,
I kind of was going too hard and the
dude was even better looking.
I was just like,
yeah,
I got to cut this out.
I gotta knock this off so this is going
to make it better looking.
You know,
it's gonna.
It's gonna make you a better looking
you.
How's that?
Because you fucking poor and that Shit
idiots not good for you.
It's like you're literally asking me
like if you live a healthier lifestyle,
you got to look a little better.
Thirty feet and moon pies and fucking
drinking beer and stuff,
you're going to look horrible.
Would you rather enjoy yourself or look
better?
Oh Dude.
I literally was thinking that last night
when I was sitting there going like,
all right,
I'm not drinking tonight.
I'm not going to have that little one.
And uh,
you know,
my wife always see I can walk in and she
hears the ice in the glass before I even
get down the hall.
And I'm giving you a hard time.
Oh,
another one.
No,
no,
no.
She just,
she doesn't.
Don't need Jeremy Sober.
No,
she's more like Christ.
You're going to be fucking snoring all
night.
Now we have cheating off.
My wife's always this.
I'll always be like,
oh my God,
I think I'm a fucking alcoholic.
She's like,
you're not an alcoholic.
You're so fucking dramatic.
He just liked to drink.
It's like,
all right,
you're right.
But um,
we did have this whole fucking thing was
she just like,
I'd come walking in with a drink and she
just spelled last year when we were
doing the show and just the stress of
writing and just thinking all day and
coming home.
But I was like really fucking hitting it
a little harder.
So I come into the room and she was
looking at my pores and they went from
this to this,
this is getting bigger.
And then one night came walking in and
she just goes,
Jesus Christ,
why don't you just bring the whole
bottle?
They're like,
I only had one fucking thing is huge.
And I,
that's what I came up.
I go,
it's a home for a home,
a home for.
Oh well you like,
you need to go out to like the fucking,
uh,
the,
the whiskey bars and shit,
and they take like an eyedropper out.
They have like a giant,
like glacier fucking ice cube in there.
And then they just,
you know,
little wet,
your whistle shot,
you just,
it doesn't even go up like an eighth of
the ice cube.
Um,
that's,
that's like a,
that's a commercial poor.
And then you've got the home pour,
which is me,
is you cover the ice cube,
he get one of those big square ones in
there,
you know,
and he just
pour over it.
I got a buddy that takes us to the next
level.
He takes a smoker,
he puts water in the smoker,
so he leaves it in there for like a half
an hour.
So the smoke embeds the water,
then he takes the water out of the
smoker and pours it into this circular
cube maker circular,
uh,
ice ball maker.
No,
you pour it,
pour it in there.
So it's smokey water.
And then he drops that in a class and
pauses whiskey over the smoke infused
water.
That too much.
It's a little redundant.
A little too.
That's like that band striper.
Remember them all.
There were the Christian band member all
the stripes.
Like they just took it too far that
everything was fucking striped.
One thing like Super Christian,
that guy's whole fucking drum kit.
Like the symbol stands were all yellow
and black striped as too much tech.
We get it.
You or you can I,
I'm not aware of these guys.
That is disgusting.
That is yellow and black.
That's what I think.
Having a smoke confused,
uh,
it's already going to be.
Have a PD taste to it?
No.
Am I wrong about them being the
Christian band?
No.
You're right.
They are.
The drummer's name was Robert.
Sweet.
I remember that.
And that was actually,
I don't think that's a stage name.
That's how I say I have no idea.
Five,
three point five.
They have a quote in the back.
That's hilarious.
They hit,
they hit.
They just the market.
Why Ted Cruz?
Oh,
that guy fixture of Ted Cruz.
And the guy,
it does look like Ted Cruz has a peewee
Herman haircut too.
Right there.
It does.
A little bit.
A Little Bob's big boy.
Little cough going on there.
I mean I should talk.
I'd be happy with him as president right
now.
I'd be happier.
Would you?
Would you not be.
He creeped me out bidding more than
trump.
Yeah.
I voted.
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I did too.
I liked that guy.
He just was.
He just was saying that's all he was
looking for at that point.
And I like Bernie Sanders too.
I would have loved to see those two guys
go at it.
I just think we would have been in a
much better place.
A more sense.
Yeah.
It just got a little too.
Uh,
we,
you know what going on with this Russia
shit.
I don't give a shit.
You don't give a shit at all.
I don't give a shit dude.
We've dealt with whatever they did.
We've done a thousand times around the
globe.
If anything,
they're,
they're guilty of stealing from us.
You tell him about tampering with the
election.
Now,
what I'm really talking about is how
much investment trump has in Russia and
what Russia has on trump.
I sound weird shit going on boys with
them.
It didn't work out well the last time
when we weren't friends.
Right.
It'd be nice to get along with them.
They don't have to try out their
missiles.
They work.
It's not like North Korea,
but they got like a fucking,
what do they call those things?
A startup,
you know,
they've got like Hashtag Fund my nuclear
missile over there.
Um,
I don't,
I refuse to get scared by that guy.
I'm not scared by him,
by Putin,
but he's a scary fucking guy.
I mean,
he's a murderer and a thug.
There's a lot of murders here,
lot of motors.
You remember that.
You've done terrible things as well.
I love when he said that.
He's right.
Well,
who,
who's the murderer?
You know,
it goes a lot of killers over here too.
And then a o'reilly goes,
well,
who,
who's the killer over here?
And he just goes that Achilles.
And then he just moves onto the next
question.
Yeah.
Nobody will be like,
no,
wait,
I asked a fucking question,
answer it,
and he'll get up and walk away.
So he does know,
says move.
He asked him questions about Russia.
He just gets up.
Fuck you.
Leaves cause you're fake news.
Fake News.
You are fake news.
Fake news outlet.
He might of sketches.
You could do with that guy.
What?
What lasted for cheating on his fucking
wife and just hop asking a question.
I'll just kept in the middle of it.
It's fake news.
Fake News.
Who's panties in these as a fake fake
Alec Baldwin's reviving his career with
them.
I mean Alex,
I've always thought that that guy has
been killing it.
He's always doing great,
but I mean it's.
He's on fire right now.
Doing is Donald Trump.
Impression I missed one of the best
things he's ever done.
That guy's fucking hilarious.
Did you ever see him on Jimeny Glick?
No fucking kid that got killed it on
everything.
He's one of the funniest dudes out there
and he's one of the best character
actors out there.
It's just that he looks like an
astronaut superhero that they tried to
make them like this matinee idol guy and
he was really like a character actor
guy.
And when he does,
uh,
my wife was always watching 30 rock,
he fucking killed it.
Do you ever see what he did?
Is Tracy Morgan impression?
No.
Yeah,
I've,
I've guy.
I'm a huge fan.
Well,
he kills it so hard on snl is trump.
I mean,
there's no way he's not funny.
I mean that,
that impression is fucking disaster.
It's destructive.
It's so good.
I love that one joke with it.
I'd like to apologize to the blah blah,
blah.
I'd like to apologize.
He kept saying Appalachian eyes and they
go,
are you trying to say trump?
You're trying to say apologize.
He gets.
No,
I would never do that.
I gotta say I've been just busy so I
haven't been watching on a Saturday
night live.
I'm going to start watching it again.
Yeah.
I don't watch it either.
I just watched the clips online.
Don't have time to invest.
Saturday night live is like one of those
things where I feel like they're going
to hit 50 percent of the time and ms dot
50 percent of the time I can't do that
so I'll just,
I'll wait for the hits.
They great.
Maybe they got very efficient way.
I'm going to finish digesting your art
so I do it bro.
Efficient.
All right.
Well we have efficiently.
We have 10 episodes this season.
I got to keep steering it back is last
year when I promoted it I just went on
things trying to be funny and then in
the end they'd be like,
oh by the way that I got to make sure I
promote it,
plug it,
plug it is for family on Netflix and if
you don't have Netflix,
how dare you.
How dare you try to live your life
without Netflix.
Does everything on it.
So kids,
my new TV,
I got a new TV doesn't even.
I mean you don't even need something to
get on Netflix.
Get on Netflix right through the TV,
the TV hooked up to Wifi,
Bam.
You know what kills me is you won't be
satisfied with that.
And within 18 months do you think
because your neighbor will have
something else.
I don't know my number.
Oh,
you're going to know your neighbors.
I had to meet my neighbor the other day
because my daughter's drone flew into
her yard.
Yeah,
we got a drone.
It sucks.
How high up does it go?
It goes high.
It's just doesn't listen to you.
If you spend 150 bucks in a drone,
it doesn't listen.
You guys spend like 500.
Then they listened
to $150.
One.
It's like a vague suggestion and once it
gets more than a few hundred feet away
from you,
that fucking thing is not listening
anymore.
It just sailed right into her tree.
So I had to go down and get it.
Amazing video and those things you.
Oh yeah,
you can if you get a good one.
Not wanting to be video.
It is fucking weird man.
I mean there was a town in Colorado that
passed a law letting you hunt them.
So if you see one of the sky,
shoot it down.
I love it.
I liked that too.
I used to have a bit about that when
Amazon was going to start delivering
packages.
I go,
that's going to be like down south.
It's gonna be like skeet shooting with
prizes
to shooting down.
What'd you?
Yeah,
just absolutely fucking shoot those
things out of the air.
That's one of the,
I one time,
uh,
I was over a friend's house.
We were at a pool one.
Just.
Yeah,
he just came home was just hovering over
the pool looking at.
It's like a fucking party.
My wife Sarah Bikinians Shit.
So what are you doing?
And I was like,
you know,
I had my usual overreaction.
Like it's just hard.
It's go to big.
It's just the future.
I will get a fucking gun.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll have a cardboard cutout of me so I
can see in the video or some shit
somehow was going to get it.
Get
Away with it.
Just in a good bird gun,
you know?
Good.
A 20 gauge,
just shoot it out of the sky.
Something that's scattered,
scatters good,
you know,
it'd be great is if you knew whose it
was and you could have somebody filming
their face when you shut this shit out
of the sky,
despite their invasion of your own
proper property.
How wrong that they would feel.
What's weird?
That's not.
There's no law above your house.
Like if someone flew that into your
house would be a problem.
If someone drove it into your yard,
it'd be a problem.
But if they hover over your house space.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's airspace.
That's fucking weird.
Right?
How does that work with like say if you
wanted to fly over Kim Kardashians house
in a helicopter and take pictures of
her.
Are you allowed to.
How's that work?
Uh,
yeah.
There's noise ordinances or like you can
only fly so fucking low.
How low a helicopter usually it's like I
wouldn't go lower than 700 feet.
Especially in Santa Monica.
Those people,
they hate that airport there and they
want all of those people out of there.
The killing that airport,
you know,
they,
they had been trying to do that for her.
Now though,
they're going to turn into a park.
All right.
Yeah.
They,
uh,
they just passed it.
It's gonna.
I think it goes out and I think it's 20
slash 20.
It goes under a three more years of a
airport.
Say though,
all those people that live in like
Marina del Rey and all those places
around there with a lot of cash and they
will park their jet there.
They're fucking pissed.
The I want to fly right in there and
just,
Oh my God,
yes.
Yeah,
that was perfect.
Well,
now they have to go to van nuys,
Torrance,
man.
Eyes.
You go to torrance,
going to be in traffic for two hours.
Uh,
yeah.
No,
that's all kind of amazing that they
passed that,
you know,
that those people couldn't figure out a
way to bribe their way.
I'm shipping that airport,
but three years is a long fucking time.
Do you remember in New York City when
they first had those videos,
you know,
advertising in the back of cabs and
everybody was like,
these are making me car sick at these
things to fuck out of here.
People had such a reaction to it,
they went away and then like a few years
later they just came back,
just came back.
Now he loves them and they fucking
gross.
Just touching that screen.
All of that.
It's bad enough being in the cabinets.
You just see the fingerprints.
It's bad enough opening and closing the
door.
But I can't see the fingerprints.
Those screens.
I,
I don't,
I don't like.
Well it's always loud too.
They're always loud and they're playing
you ads and some entertainment news,
tv show or something like that.
Yup.
I feel like a hypocrite because I do
advertise on my podcast.
So how mad can I get?
But I do draw the line when I go to pump
gas,
like gas,
TV,
blah,
blah blah.
And they just pumping it super loud.
You do ads on your progress,
but you should in the ads,
like I heard you're doing an ad for me
undies with the new one where they're
doing with the,
uh,
the gay pride thing.
And you're like,
it.
It's just like,
it's very hard to get,
I think,
straight guys to get into like or
animals,
you know what I mean?
We don't,
we don't have the sense of style.
Maybe you get a couple of Metro sexuals,
but yeah,
it just felt like that was a great.
Like what can we,
what can we pretend to care about that
will get us to sell more underwear?
And that was,
that was the way to fucking go.
I'm bored.
I just say things I don't fuck.
It just felt like that was,
you know what it really is.
I have two pairs and they're very.
Greg Louganis,
I'll tell you,
he got little ones,
the little ones and I put them on to
make my wife left and she did laugh,
but she goes,
no,
I kind of like,
um,
like thesis.
Just too little.
I get the boxer briefs.
Oh,
they have boxer briefs.
That's all I wear.
I'm wearing them right now.
I don't believe you.
I'm joking.
I thought,
you know what?
For some reason I thought you would have
like the tear away fight once.
Oh,
the Polka dot.
That's great.
That looks like a yogurt shit that they
have.
The Yoga,
whatever.
The sprinkles.
Tcby sprinkles in your frozen fro.
Yo.
I'm alright.
Have I kept you here long enough?
I think I have this kind of.
Is this going to be traffic you got to
get out of here?
I don't know.
I just,
I just wasn't sure who can't figure out
if the point you're showing me your
underwear it thinks and it fucking
pattern that we've kind of covered it.
So if there's anything else you want to
bring up all the.
What have you shot lately?
Uh,
animal wise.
Shot a pig a couple months ago.
Oh well shit.
Fuck the animals.
What else did you shoot?
No,
just animals.
Okay.
Yeah,
there was something else.
No,
no,
no.
So you inching towards crusher.
I'll give you some pigmeat.
Damn,
I don't have it here.
Shit.
Motherfucker.
I always get the elk.
I'll give you an alkyne pig.
I still have the elk leftover from the
last name.
Okay.
I have plenty of elk,
but uh,
uh,
I want the wild boar.
I'll give you a,
like a,
like a fucking
real,
a real leg leg.
Like a boar leg.
Yeah.
I live in a house,
man.
I don't have the fucking,
the fucking serial killer meat freezer
that I know that you have.
We just got to tell me when you're going
to cook and I'll give it to you the day
you cook it.
All right.
No,
that's not gonna happen.
That was one of those,
you know,
I'll go on youtube and fill out.
They'll go to fucking how to cook a uh,
a peg leg.
Yeah.
We've just got to slow cook it.
Just slow co Brian.
At first I'd like to.
Brian thinks,
you know,
you ever used those Yeti coolers?
You know what a Yeti cooler is?
It's like a super,
really cold.
It's a very insulated cooler.
Like you could put ice in it and leave
it outside in the sun and five days
later I'll still have ice.
Okay.
So you take one of those,
put some ice in it and some sort of a
bucket.
Fill the bucket up with a saltwater June
and sugar.
Yeah,
a bunch of Shit in there.
Garlic,
stuff like that,
and then Brian,
Brian to meet and make an extra 10.
So she's a witch and then it just,
just like Brian and he's just such an
old school thing.
Tie somebody to a stake.
And then at that point the uh,
you don't have heard,
they never really.
They weren't really burning witches at
the stake.
That was bullshit.
They would drown them.
I'm like,
well,
that's just as terrifying why you got to
go drowning.
Yeah.
GotTa go with drowning buys that o two
is for fucking minute or a blog said you
just pick a big inhale.
I think what they would do is if,
if they would figure if you didn't
drown,
you were definitely a which and if you
drowned,
they fucked up my bed.
Which somebody stole something because
there's a lot of weird shit going on,
you know?
How do you get out of that one?
That's amazing though,
that that's what they used to think.
They used to think that someone was
doing witchcraft when things would go
wrong.
I don't think that's amazing because I
think that's.
That kind of thought is just slid into
other shit that people think,
you know.
Do you know what the root of it was in
the Salem witch trials?
It was a.
They got a late frost and they're bread
like apparently when you get a late
frost and wheat you can get some weird
mold that grows on the wheat and this
wheat was growing.
This type of mold called Ercot in Ercot
has the same properties as LSD.
So these people were eating the bread
and tripping their fucking balls off and
they thought that keep dm hat's really
freaky with a belt buckle on your hat of
the belt buckle and your shoes.
And we used to have those stupid buckles
on their shoes.
I'm sorry,
I did the go,
go.
I did the comedy comic thing.
Go ahead.
So anyways,
so they're tripping on this shit.
And so they thought that these people
were bewitched,
they thought they were getting,
which they were getting hex by witches,
and so they had these people that they
didn't trust and they were freaking out
because they were on acid.
And that's one of the primary theories
that crazy.
You imagine being on acid in the 17
hundreds,
how much you'd be freaking out.
Yeah,
I mean there's no information
on it.
Once I actually,
I thought some of the,
uh,
the original people,
whatever you supposed to call them now,
indigenous people.
You're not supposed to say the natives.
I fucking said that in Canada and
somebody can I view the,
the.
Oh,
ogs and Canada have enabled them
original or first nation.
First nation.
Yeah.
They have a different name for them.
We can have first responders.
They got weird rules in Canada.
Do you know they can go out at night
with flashlights and shoot deer and
Moose.
They flash flashlights on them and all
year round they don't have any,
any rules.
They have that in America too.
Like,
uh,
they don't have like game laws for the
native American reservation areas.
Like they can just no flashlights.
Um,
I'm actually doing a Gig for the cops
tomorrow.
What are you doing to some of the
California Highway Patrol?
Where it's a good move.
I don't know.
Yeah,
you can never know enough cops.
Never know.
Never know enough cops.
You had no idea when you're going to
snap and you're going to need a cop to
show up.
Oh Joe,
get outta here.
Come on.
You're not hurt that bad buddy.
Walk it off.
You'll be fine.
Um,
I think that all the motorcycle guys I
want to talk to.
I was hoping I was going to,
uh,
meet some of the helicopter pilots
because those fucking gay flat like 300
feet.
The balls.
This guys here,
they're really.
Yeah,
they were other people's houses and they
got to sit there and a fucking circle.
Yay for like an hour or nauseous looking
at it first moved to La.
This girl I was dating a right outside
of her house.
Someone broke into someone's house and
they had the helicopter flying overhead.
It was fucking creepy.
Like you look outside the window,
you'd see the spotlight moving across
the city street down to the Improv is
the building still exists if you park
just east of uh,
of crescent heights is a building on the
second floor.
They have ceiling to floor windows and
something with somebody broke in there
and they had like the,
the,
the helicopter spotlight was on it.
And I watched two cops,
like a movie walking down that hallway
with their guns drawn.
Slowly walking in,
just sitting there.
Like,
what the fuck is this?
Yeah,
it was like,
probably like four months into moving
here.
The craziest Shit I ever saw with cops
live was on TV during the North
Hollywood shootout.
Where you in La back then?
I was in Vegas,
but I was living in La.
Yeah.
Those guys,
they had the head to toe body armor.
They had head to toe body armor trunks
filled with guns.
They're all steroid it up out of their
fucking mind.
Crazy probably on meth had just gone to
some of that trip and.
Yep.
That was,
that was crazy.
That was crazy.
We were,
uh,
on news radio.
It was a,
we're in the lunch room,
like our break room watching on tv
going,
what in the fuck,
just live shooting from there too.
I would have retired the next day as a
cop.
I would have been like,
is this what the future is?
And I mean,
you're going to give me this little
fucking pea shooter.
Like this is what I'm supposed to do.
I'm done.
A lot of them did.
I'm sure I would've.
That would've been when they will
fucking crouched behind that car and
that guy.
Remember that guy spraying the.
I love how people going to go will open
shot.
The Guy who was clearly hurt there.
I mean they wouldn't pull them away.
They let them bleed out.
He got shot under the vest.
You got like took one under the vest and
the gut and they let him bleed out and
people were complaining.
Good.
Yeah,
exactly.
Good.
That's what you get.
My mother would have said,
well,
you shot at the place.
That's what you get.
You know now yellow,
maybe there's reincarnation.
You'll,
you'll learn next time you're supposed
to be above.
I got more kids.
Love that.
If you're a peace officer for whatever
reason.
No,
that's stupid.
I agree.
That's like an athlete's when someone
says fucking crazy shit to your face.
Use.
We were supposed to be above that.
No,
you can't.
You them.
Right.
In the perfect world,
in a perfect world,
some woman on twitter,
Lady Lady,
some lady on twitter was harassing
Donald Trump and Donald Trump blocked
her,
which is hilarious.
So she showed that Donald trump blocked
her and then she said she's contacting a
lawyer and she said that the president
shouldn't be able to block her and
everybody's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And then people started harassing her so
she started blocking people and they're
like,
listen,
you fucking crazy bitch.
This is what's called a hypocrite.
You can't do that.
Shrink him in the White House.
You know when you scroll with both your
thumbs just sitting there and typing
like this is what he's doing.
Blocking people on twitter.
Yeah.
He blocks people to,
you know what else he does?
He watches five hours of TV a day.
How the fuck does he have time?
I don't have time to watch five hours of
TV a day.
People know how to delegate.
That's what he's doing.
He's delegating his time to the vice
president.
I bet he looks at him like he's his ward
and just,
you know,
military codes are over there and just
handed.
He's still in our team talking about me
this bad.
I got.
I don't know.
I look,
I couldn't handle that fucking job to
Howard stern had the funniest fucking
take on him on Donald trump was saying
like,
why the fuck would you take that job at
Urh?
He goes,
you got,
you got like eight good summers left.
He goes,
you're going to spend that taken all
this shit.
He just kept going back to that.
You get eight summers lift.
He kept to get good take on it.
It was fucking hilarious and it was.
It was perfect.
Why would you do that?
The like you're a fucking billionaire.
Just go enjoy your money.
Ego could do it all.
Could do it all.
I could be the fucking president because
they trashed him at the brunch 100
percent.
He was like,
fuck you.
I'll show you.
Because they,
they mocked him,
made fun of them because that was during
the birth,
put him right in the middle of the room.
Do you know every roast is always that
raw meat guy and you don't realize you
have that guy until all of a sudden the
roast starts as just like,
Oh fuck,
I'm the guy.
I'm the guy for when everybody runs out
of jokes for the guy that they're
hosting that,
that they're roasting.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
that's,
it's brutal.
Yeah.
And he,
he was,
you know,
and they said one thing to them that was
hilarious,
like,
but um,
one thing that you'll never be the
president of the United States.
That was one of the things that Obama
said.
Yeah.
And he shot them all and he
the fucking hand over the keys to the
house.
I mean,
that had to abandon.
Oh my God,
we never saw it coming.
There's no way.
No Way.
This guy's gonna run.
No of this guy's gonna win.
No.
And in a weird way,
it was sort of like a reverse like bully
movie because it was the liberals don't
want it to them and they were totally
bullying the guy 100 percent,
but he was bullying Obama with the whole
fucking thing,
the birther thing.
Right.
So I dunno,
they're still going after that birth is
shit.
I saw something yesterday on some
website that was showing how they have
all these different confirmed sources
that are showing that the Obama birth
certificate was fake and I hope it was
fake.
So I hope you unto his presidency and
already happened.
What do you,
what can you do?
But I hope it was fake.
I hope he scammed the country.
Listen,
the fucking the NBA had that mobbed up
ref.
And he said that he fucked the warriors.
And I mean the,
uh,
the kings out of that series against the
Lakers.
No one's going to take the fucking
Lakers title away for that year.
Really?
Is that real?
Yeah.
What is it?
He was a referee who's fucking fixing
games?
No,
really that's how much you don't watch
sports.
So you know,
it would fit him.
Donna,
he 100 percent of NBA reps gamble,
but he's also like,
he's in jail now.
He's just trying to say shit.
But like this is the guy that was the
ref that was in jail.
Yeah.
But like he,
he sat him right there.
Yeah.
He fixed gay.
He used to say from in jail.
He goes,
you tell me who's reffing the game?
And I'll tell you who wins.
Wow.
He spent 15 months in prison after
pleading guilty to charges the case.
He's out freedom.
How much you do
you think he made?
He joined callen.
Colin cowherd Wednesday afternoon.
Had a fascinating answer.
When asked what percentage?
He said 100.
Wow.
That's.
No,
no,
not true.
No,
that's just a fucking jail bird.
Talk it.
I used to gamble on UFC fights way back
in the early days when I first started
working for them.
I was like,
who gives a shit?
I can't really affect the outcome.
So like in many,
many years ago,
like I would,
they would,
they bring in these guys,
like they bring in some guy from Brazil
that I knew about and I would look at
the line of like,
you guys are out of your fucking mind,
this guy,
she'd be like a 10 to one favorite and
you've got an underdog.
I'm like,
Ooh,
I'm putting some money on that.
And I put some money on it.
But then after awhile it's like,
this is probably not smart,
you know,
I don't think it's illegal because I
can't speak for the company.
No,
it's also not good for me.
See if I come off as biased anyway,
you know,
I've been accused of being a biased
commentator anyway.
Tap Out.
Come on,
come by.
Yeah.
But,
um,
that's a,
that's a different kind of thing though.
Gambling when you're a referee is a big
deal.
Yeah.
And that's a game that's easily fixed.
How do they fix it?
What do they do?
Because you can,
you can take stars out of the game by
giving them false.
Oh,
is that what they did?
Yeah.
We just,
you just sit people down.
It's just like if you're the best player
on the team and the first quarter I give
you two quick fouls,
I'm not going to see you again until the
second quarter and I've never fixed a
fucking game,
but I mean I'm just,
you know,
I'm just,
I give you another one in the second
quarter.
I don't see it to the next half and at
some point you're going to get mad if I
keep calling bullshit files,
I might get you in a technical foul that
saves me a ticky tack file that counts
towards your files and then two files to
tacticals you're out of the game.
You're rejected.
So was it obvious that this guy was
doing files that it was.
I thought it was obvious that the NBA
was kind of fixed for a while.
Like I was sitting going late.
Yeah.
I just,
I went to a game one time,
the Celtics versus Utah Jazz and I'm
watching the fucking game and like just
like the game starts that letting them
play and then they're calling it tight
and then they're letting them play.
Then they're calling it tight and it's
like there was never an ebb and flow and
how they will call in a game.
It's like a,
an empire,
you know,
you've seen the first day and it got
step out of the box going,
okay,
that's a strike tonight.
Okay,
cool.
Just finding out where you strike zone
is,
but like an empire,
if you start changing the strike zone,
kind of change in sports on your hair,
like people are going to know like what
the fuck's going on?
You got to be consistent.
So like with um,
NBA reps,
we,
NBA Games you would watch and it's just
like,
oh,
they're calling a close tonight.
Oh,
he's letting the boys play.
And like that was the game.
They wouldn't just keep obviously if it
got really out of hand they would
tighten down.
But I never saw a game where it's just
like you're pulling back on the range,
you'll let them run,
you pulling back,
you letting them run.
And it just made me feel like they were
shaving points is something I remember
for years.
I said the game was fixed and um,
everybody said I was out of my fucking
mind and then they find a guy who's all
mobbed up,
but I go there vindication.
They go,
oh,
it's just one guy.
Now when you say mobbed up,
like how was he mobbed up?
What was,
what was the issue with Dr?
I was just an expression,
I don't want to get in trouble with
anybody,
but he was basically working for other
people that were part of a gambling that
took a bookies or whatever.
And he did something to make sure that
the,
the game leaned in that direction,
like you couldn't totally fix it.
So if a team was favored by eight and
they want them to win by eight,
he'd make sure it happened to probably.
It's probably easier to make sure they
didn't buy fucking over their offense
and then they were just,
you know,
they try to get money,
like,
look,
if you're legit,
bookie,
all you're trying to do is get an even
amount of money on each side.
Right,
okay.
Because with the combination of people
teasing it and plus the juice and all of
that,
you're going to end up on top.
You don't want a bunch of money all on
one side and losing your fucking shirt.
So what these guys would do is you get
greedy after awhile.
It's like,
I'm sick of this ticky tack Shit.
Let's go for a big fucking score.
And they wouldn't do it every game.
They just every once in a while and be
like,
alright listen,
here's a gay probably,
you know,
I don't,
I don't have that fixed the fucking
game.
I'm just guessing how they would go
about doing it to fix this one.
All right,
sure.
These guys don't win by eight.
So this guy admitted that he fixed it.
Oh yeah.
The J was somebody went to jail for
gambling on it.
Right.
For fixing or fixing it.
So what did he say?
He said like he made fouls that weren't
really fouls.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
You do whatever he had to do.
This attorney submitted saying the
manipulation that happened during one
game.
Okay.
So officiating playoff series feeding
team five and team six in May of 2002 as
a six game of a seven game series and a
team five victory that night would have
ended the series.
However tim learned from referee a that
referees a and f wanted to extend the
series of seven games.
Tim knew referees a and F to B company,
men in quotes,
uh,
always acting in the interest of the
NBA.
And that night it was the NBA is
interest add another game.
So the NBA wanted to fix it,
follow the NBA,
fixing referees a and f heavily favored
teams.
Six personal fouls resulting in
obviously injured players were ignored
even when they occurred in full view of
the referees.
Conversely,
the referees called meetup fouls on team
flower.
Yeah,
the highlights of the Lakers kings game.
It was ridiculous.
The files that they will come.
But that's my thing is when they said it
was just one guy,
it's like,
how long could you be on an officiating
crew while the in,
in one of your guys is dirty before
you'd realize like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
Well,
what about the guys that we're betting
on the other team?
I'd want to kill that fucking referee.
Can you imagine if you saw him call
fouls and weren't really fouls in you
knew,
you knew your money was going out the
window.
But I think they're really susceptible
to it because like the amount of money
that NBA players
because fucking insane.
They make like,
you know,
some of the contracts that they have
coming up and this.
So there's so few guys on the team and
there's like every year the draft is
like two rounds in the draft.
Like fucking nfl goes on forever is 40
something guys on a team in the NFL.
There's 20 something in baseball,
20 something in,
uh,
in the NHL.
And I think,
I think basketball,
it's no more than 11 or 12 guys.
So it's a very small group of people in
the income that they're generating their
revenue share.
I don't know how I like,
to all that's all like super sports nerd
shit.
Like I don't know how that works,
but some of the contracts that they,
that some of these guys have been
signing,
like they can afford to fucking pay that
guy that.
So now you're a ref and you're running
with your fucking black aerobic reebok
sneakers up and down the court,
you know the velcade yet.
Yes.
And just seeing the cars these guys are
getting in and all the women hanging out
and you're on the stage two,
you're running up and down.
No one gives a fuck about you.
And uh,
I don't know what the pension is for the
NBA,
but like if I was in the NBA I would,
if I was running I'd be like,
we gotta fucking triple these guys'
salary.
Is this the salaries of the players of
the referees NBA player salaries for.
What?
About the referees though?
Oh,
so look at that.
Thirty $5 million a year for Lebron.
That's just,
that's just what he makes the play hoop.
Not about
sneaker contracts are like more than
what they make.
It's fucking nuts.
It's nuts.
It's a lot of canned goods for them.
I'm not,
I'm not saying they should make the
money.
Obviously if people putting it out there
earning,
but like find.
Can you put up what a ref makes?
Do you know who Mike Conley is?
That's what's hilarious.
I only know like the biggest guys are.
That might cause them who.
That's my commonly fucks.
I don't know who that is.
Either.
Dry made $30,000,000
last year
is the highest paid player in the NBA.
He says because the contract.
This is a guy named Mike Conley.
Yeah,
he was.
He's the starting point guard for the
Memphis Grizzlies.
Yeah.
Oh there you go.
Let's find a matter of time,
like his contract came up at the time
last year and the uh,
when the rest of the guys are going to
get more of this coming year and the
following year the TV contracts have
gone up and there's a percentage.
They're going up each year based off of
the TV rights and that's why I watched
almost every Celtic game last year.
I never heard my con Mike Conley.
That sounds like a fucking tissue.
Which Ohio state sent me.
Was Greg Gordon who was the big bust and
he was just the point guard.
Is He still playing in China?
No,
no,
he's actually Ohio state assistant coach
right now.
He went back to school for
Planar China.
That's when it gets weird.
Right,
and you got to go overseas to Europe
playing for 100 grand a year and you're
like,
Ooh.
I don't know.
Sometimes if you're famous enough
they'll.
They'll give you a little more.
I don't know how that works either.
I don't know how that shit works.
I just know I have a show coming out
called F is for family.
That's why I'm here.
The average salary that'd be a rep is
from a hundred 50 grand to 550 grand.
That's a big spread.
What about the guy who's making the
extra four?
How's he getting extra?
For average,
salaries of spiked considerably since
1983 when NBA officials made between
18,070
8,000
each season.
Five hundred 50 grand is not bad.
That's a lot of scratch.
She'd have to give them enough money
where they don't feel tempted to cheat.
Right?
Yeah.
That's the problem with politicians.
You make 550 grand a year.
You're making 50 grand a year more than
the president,
so you kind of like.
Those guys are like set up to be like,
here's a job that cost $100 million to
get and you're going to get paid 500
grand so that you just setting them up
to have to cut deals with people.
What do you think is gonna happen with
trump?
I have no idea.
I don't even know the highest paid guy
in the NBA.
I have a few.
If you had a guest though,
do you think this is gonna?
This is gonna last.
Yes.
You don't think he's going to go to jail
and I'm in the middle of.
No,
no.
I watched Clinton getting phd stayed.
Right.
But Clinton got impeached for just not
telling the truth about an affair.
Nixon should have stayed.
Think so.
He should've just stayed and just being
like,
you know,
alright,
I booked that room.
I apologize for the American people.
And that's it.
I think the stress is too much for them
though.
When the whole world comes after.
I'm like that.
Everywhere you look,
every newspaper,
I think,
uh,
I think we'll be fine.
He's fucking watching five hours of TV
and he's on twitter blocking people.
I mean,
what else?
Fluffing other sandwich.
I mean,
he's living like a fucking kid.
Well,
it's hard to see.
When you read articles about them,
it's hard to know who's writing the
article and why they're writing it.
Right?
Like are they writing this article
because they really believe that he's
gaining weight and he's solemn.
Then he's down in the dumps or are they
trying to just put that out there?
Like how the fuck did they know?
He's down in the dumps that's trying to
sell papers.
How they know he's Sullen and comes home
upset and he's gaining weight.
He does seem like you're gaining weight
though.
Simply like getting little fat,
little depression.
Well,
I made this.
Obviously most of the people,
it seems in the media fucking hate the
guy.
So they're going to be just just.
Yeah,
but that's how you chip away at your.
Right.
So talking about how you're coming home
when you're depressed or you're
despondent,
you're not listening to anybody you had.
How do they know that?
Our sort of say,
how do they know that our sources say
negative things about the guys we don't
like?
Well you were talking about tiger woods
on your podcast.
I was listening to it on the way over
here and I totally agree with you were
just saying like when tigers world fell
apart,
like how the fuck do you know?
Like what do you,
what did you talk to him like you don't
know him.
Yeah,
give it to have a conversation.
And it was a brutal couple of years,
but it was 10 years ago and in 10 years
he hasn't fucked up other than this Dui.
So I mean,
yeah,
he fucked up.
But Hey,
you know,
89,
so I'm going to judge him.
Right?
The Dui,
apparently he's on some back medication.
That's what it is.
He mixed his medication.
That's what he's saying.
But they said he smelled like booze.
But I don't know if that's true.
She just take the hit and just be like,
ah,
you know,
I fucked up.
I was hanging out with the fellas,
blah blah blah.
I'm not kidding.
I'm not condoning what the guy did,
but I'm not gonna sit there and judge
the guy and be like,
I was watching some guy and he was
trying to say that,
you know,
you know he let us down.
He,
he sold himself as a family man.
It's like you built that whole fucking
narrative.
Know you built that whole.
Now I just watched him play golf.
All I ever want to do when I watch golf
is watched those guys fucking crush it.
Like I love John Daly and I love that.
He's like,
fuck you.
I like drank.
And he just kept drinking and smoking
cigarettes.
Cigarettes big.
Yeah.
When he hit it a fucking mile.
And I loved watching it.
Well,
tiger always had a very bizarre style.
Apparently I don't play golf,
but apparently people that I've talked
to that explained to me the way he would
hit the ball like this,
not the way they teach you to do it,
but he could do it so well that way,
but he would put like ridiculous amounts
of Torque.
Yes.
On his,
on his boat.
And they,
they said from the beginning that his
body was going to break down if he keeps
doing that.
There was a period where he adjusted his
swing and he stopped.
He stopped winning and then he came back
again.
And um,
I just think that what they said there
was a bunch of guys,
Earl Campbell,
they said if he keeps running like that,
he's wide open.
He's going to have problems.
Bobby or the way he played hockey with
you throw yourself around.
He really beat the shit out of your
body.
Like that happens.
And it just coincided with his personal
life falling apart.
So everybody goes,
oh,
that's the reason why you know somebody
wins.
That's the reason why somebody loses
like,
look,
I'm not saying you don't go to a couple
of your funk if you.
Yeah,
your life falls apart in the personal
area,
but it's just like
the rest of that shit,
you know,
that was.
I mean that's just a bunch of hype.
Like for him it's like,
okay,
doubled dump though,
you know.
I mean the thing happens personally with
his personal life and it happens
publicly where everybody gets to see it
and then on top of that his body's
falling apart at the same time
no matter what he did.
Yeah.
No matter where you went to church every
fucking week he was going to fuck up his
back and his knees and they.
And it did.
But then they're trying to equate it to
a,
you know,
whatever.
The.
I think what he did was none of my
business.
It's none of my fucking business.
I don't want to know about it.
I hate no one about,
you know,
I feel bad if somebody like,
if the marriage falls apart,
I feel bad.
If they get busted for and drop,
you know,
I mean it happens.
If you fucked up and it's your fault,
you should get punched,
but like the cops are handling it.
They arrested him,
the courts will handle it.
Do I need to talk to?
I need a pile on and start wagging my
fucking hypocrite.
Middle Finger out of my pasty freckled.
You don't have to because you're a
comedian and you're funny and your take
on things can be.
Have some compassion and look at it for
what it is.
Make Fun,
poke at it,
but when you're one of those fucking
straight up sports commentator guys,
you don't have a whole lot of wiggle
room as far as what you could say and
what you don't say and you got to go
right down the middle and attack.
You've got to go to Disney couples.
Yeah,
go Disney.
I mean,
what does this say about the fabric of
our community?
You know,
the morals of our conduct creates a
culture.
Look at this.
Tiger woods is lost and every literal
and figurative way by Iun O'connor,
espn sports,
tiger woods.
You met in Jupiter,
Florida police report is not the tiger
woods presented to you by tiger,
his sponsors and his reps that woods.
So here's the thing,
what this is fucking espn,
those guys on tv,
what they present is not who the fuck
they are looking at this
Nicholas,
they're saying that woods is a new and
improved human beings since his extra
marital sex scandal from hell,
a better father and friend with or
without a golf and his like.
How do you.
Would she have sympathy for the guy who
wrote this because he got it Kinda has
to sit down and they got Jesus Christ.
How am I going to keep being a senior
writer unless I act like this shit
actually bothers me.
You have to write something
inflammatory.
You have to write something salacious.
He gotta you gotta get people to Click.
You got to get a lot of clickbait.
Why can't this fat fuck shutoff is
fireworks in his country to his son.
We do it all the time.
We fucking lights shut off in the ocean.
Kill all this fish that people could
have eight till Wales.
Yeah.
Kill fucking whales with tests.
And then this fucking guy shoots off a
rocket and everybody's,
oh,
hey,
what are you doing?
Boys threatening us.
Bill threatened in America attitude.
I,
you know,
I worried that we're coming.
I love this shit talker.
Probably hear,
oh well we are for sure with trump.
I pitched this on somebody else's
podcast.
What they should do,
they should eliminate war and then what
it is is your leaders go into the
octagon.
They're not allowed to work out or
anything.
Not Allowed to work out.
No.
They go in the fucking off.
So you get to see like,
like right now,
who's your number one world leader?
I got to go boat.
And yet 100 percent.
CSI,
judo,
black belt.
Izzy.
He looks like he fucking head.
But you know,
he's a judo black belt.
He'll fuck up every other world where
100 percent just pictured him choking
out.
Trump says he would kill trump.
He would trip them.
Can you imagine the ground?
Can you imagine the sound of his foot
hitting the side of this guy's sons
belly?
Just a nice fucking liver shot.
Will be the funniest shit ever.
And everybody sits there and like
whatever you,
whatever the dispute is.
This is our territory.
That's Terry.
It's just solved with world leader,
mixed martial arts.
You go and you can do whatever you want.
It'd be like the early days of that shit
when the guy came in with the one boxing
glove,
like trump,
trump could still wear a tie with like
the little tight shorts on and he could
keep wingtip shoes on if you want to
keep.
You can do whatever the fuck you want to
do within reason.
I don't want,
I don't want to be too violent,
but they just have to fucking,
oh to be hilarious.
Because what?
First of all that fucking doesn't the
uh,
the sun have to wear glasses too.
And uh,
in uh,
the Kim Jong Il part to the cul the sun
caddyshack.
Does he wear glasses?
Yeah.
So He'd have to come in with the Kareem
goggles,
you know,
prescription level,
like a basketball player if they make
those in North Korea,
you know what I mean?
Don't get into the China.
China's onto them,
their friends to solve it that way
through the job.
Be a laptop custom painted.
That looks like a better color than
mine.
No,
the new ones come in.
Two colors that come into the dark gray
or a light gray,
a dark gray one.
I have to throw my out and I'm going to
personally put mine in the ocean.
Do you have the brand new one that gets
throwing mine in the ocean?
Don't do that.
To kill some sea life for kids and what
do they do?
See all the porn I used to watch and
then they fucking gets you stuck
shooting.
They start shooting missiles off.
I'm all right,
dude.
Get out of here before the traffic gets
so much.
My pleasure,
brother.
Thank you for the offer of the pig leg.
I'll take that off your next time.
Alright is for family today.
It's one of the funniest fucking shows
you will ever watch in your life.
It's on Netflix right now.
Goal Binge Binge.
You freaks.
Thank you.